throughout the corona virus pandemic
much of the nation's attention has been
focused on densely populated cities but
the virus has also had a devastating
effect on small towns and we saw the
dramatic impact on businesses in one
small Pennsylvania community where
people tend to know each other and the
losses can feel more personal but we
also found that small talents might have
a better chance of writing out this
economic storm along Main Street USA
stores are cautiously reopening and some
people are venturing out but life is
just not the same on a normal day in
June would you be able to sit here at
lunchtime no Nicole - for open quench
cafe in 2009 after the New York
investment firms she worked for Lehman
Brothers collapsed in the mortgage
meltdown she moved in with family here
in Stroudsburg Pennsylvania population
5,500 and while the setting may be
different the feeling of financial loss
is familiar with revenue down 90% so how
do you pay rent just really you pay for
the building rather than pay your own
salary yeah Wow so that's not that's not
like a theoretical loss or business loss
or loss on paper that's like your loss
yeah it's it's it's a significant and
it's it's personal yeah absolutely
it turns out everything is a little more
personal in a town like this just down
the block
Andrea Snyder lost thousands of dollars
laid off her staff at Jade hair salon 25
years you've been a business yes
have you ever closed prior to this no no
how when you had cancer nope
two times we need kids in the second
time no never
when we stopped by she was preparing for
business to start up again but her
biggest loss from this pandemic is the
kind she'll never recover we did
everything we could
my mother was surrounded by the most
wonderful nurses and aides and they
brought her to the window when we went
there to see her and try
it's the hardest thing it's the distance
it's not being able to be with your
loved ones not being able to hug and
kiss and tell them that you love them
after all she's been through
Schneider says she's amazed by the
support she's getting here if we can
just hold it together you know we just
have to hold it together we have to keep
our hearts in the right place so this
way we can move forward how do you think
your neighbors are doing your town is
doing you know I mean there are some
people that are just not able to come
back but you know we'll take care of
them everybody will gather around and
we'll you know we'll do what needs to be
done that spirit it seems is a
characteristic of small towns a
particular thing that people often are
craving at this moment in American
history which is a sense of connection
james Fallows spent years visiting
places other people drive past or
flyover and along with his wife wrote a
book on the topic he says no other city
has been impacted more by the virus than
America's largest New York until now the
longer-term concern about what it will
take to rebuild - Rhea tract residents
to restore small businesses to regain a
sense of momentum that concern is more
widespread in smaller towns and they
think they have a longer road ahead of
them
and what if anything about the qualities
in small towns makes you hopeful they
will survive a town that has already
been around for a hundred years or more
has already been through a lot it was
through the Great Depression it was
through world wars it's been through the
financial shocks of the last 20 or 30
years so people there know how to
reinvent themselves their challenge will
be to reinvent themselves yet again yet
reinvention could be tough for people
like record store owner Tom Lefevre
record store would seem like they're
partially about the people who come to
them the browsing the talking with a guy
behind the counter and for sure it's
definitely a personal experience that
experience has changed a bit
Mean Street jukebox a shop that's
already survived among other things the
age of digital music so how long has it
been since someone walked in the door
like I just did a couple months have you
ever had anything like that before like
any kind of stretch where you just
couldn't do business I have actually 12
13 years ago I was across the street
that was where my business was and there
was a fire and I lost my whole business
Wow well I was down for probably a
couple months until I got insurance
money and then I landed in here but
insurance covers a fire does it cover
this does not cover this how did you
feel when you found that out it was it
was a big big shock to be honest but I
was kind of angry too the anger and
sorrow along this Main Street isn't much
different than anywhere else but if
you're gonna go through a bad time
Nicole defore says this is a good place
to do it people are just asking how am i
doing because they want to make sure we
stay around and we stay you know
relevant and we get through this and
like and you I can feel that I can feel
that they really care when they ask me
how we're doing like how do you how do
you put a price on that that's that's
amazing
so what also is amazing is the
resiliency in these towns and then Gail
we talked about Boston strong or New
York strong or Houston strong but
there's definitely a small town strong
out there as well I love a good small
town listen I love Andrea Snyder's
pigtails when I go if I go there I'd
want to go to quench cafe to say hi to
Nicole of all the places how did you
happen to pick that place go to the Main
Street jukebox looked likes a great
place how did you pick that blue wanted
to find a place that was within driving
distance does we wanna get on a plane
and that wasn't directly connected to
some other major city like New York or
Boston and also had fewer than 25,000
people which is kind of the threshold
millions of Americans live in towns
smaller than 25,000 people glue to my
mom you do get an incredible strength in
a small community like that and you know
it's a good community when they have a
good record store that's really that's
you know a good way